على كل حال عصيره الحب
سنتعرف على اليمن الجميل الوجه الجميل
والوجه المحب لليمن
والكلور اليمني معها الفرقه الموسيقيه
الجميله نبقى معها ونختم في امان الله الى
اللقاء ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
حتى يوم القيامه حتى يوم القيامه
هو انت
يا في جمالك مو زيك
امامك شي علينا ملامه غير في نظره الخد
الاصيل المورط من روابي تهامه من روابي
تهامه ليله دان يا ليله دان دانه
[موسيقى]
صبر على الصبر ساعه
عسى بعد الصبر نشرب من الحالي
[موسيقى]
والصبر عند العرب طاعه
وعقبال الصبر
مضمونه قولوا يا زارعين العنب
[موسيقى]
وبالانه
ربي
على قلبي
وانس
عذابتهم قلبي
تبيعونا
[موسيقى]
لما
ياسهير العين
ما تموت
[موسيقى]
النجمات
ايام زمان
[موسيقى]
وايه كمان اساليه البحريه ايه ده انا اسف
علي بجنوبي وشمالي
مع سعاسه شيخ خبر سري يطمن نفسه
يا زارعين العنب ماما تبيعونه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وصابر على الصبر ساعه عسى بعد الصبر يشرف
من الحالي
والصبر عند العرب طاعه وعقبال الصبر
مضمونه
[موسيقى]
يقولوا قولوا يا زارعين العنب